Fewer
since you've been gone,
things have gotten much worse.
Ah, You think I came back?
You're in no shape for this fight
that lies before us.
Old friend.
This is personal.
Very few of us know about the wars
fought in the shadows
that have raged on this planet.
Do you feel responsible?
Where are the Avengers?
This war is one I have to fight alone.
You're the most wanted man on the planet.
You don't know what
they have planned for you.
The great Nick Fury.
One last fight.
Welcome back
everyone, it's Charlie. Marvel
just dropped another brand new secret
invasion
trailer with a bunch of new footage
that will break it all down.
There's a whole bunch Easter eggs.
If you're brand new to the channel,
I'll be doing videos for the episodes.
Jessica do for all the other
Marvel Disney Plus series.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
Just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage,
we see Nick Fury coming to this area
in the woods is fenced off.
It seems like the same grave site
where he goes to see his own tombstone,
like they make believe that he's died
and that's why he's been gone.
This is probably something that happens
after the events
of the Spider-Man
Far from Home Post-Credits
scene where TALOS and his wife have been
pretending to be Nick Fury, Maria Hill.
He's reunited with TALOS
since he's come back, and they explain
that he hasn't been back to Earth
since the events of Avengers Endgame.
And Taylor is basically catches him
up on everything that's been happening.
Things have gotten much, much worse
in what he's talking about
is the group of skrulls
within his larger group of good skrulls
that have turned dissident
in order to try and replace world
leaders taking over the earth
like comic book secret invasion.
The main villain is graphic.
This character here, I know
it seems like he has some special powers.
He might just have more developed
abilities to shapeshift
and that's what he's doing here.
It seems like he's doing the same thing
that Groot did, making his limb grow
really big during Avengers Infinity War.
It's the same basic concept.
It does seem like
there might be some Super Skrull
Easter eggs during this,
like they're trying
to create a Super Skrull,
but I think these particular skrulls
just might have more advanced abilities,
but they themselves aren't a group
of super skrulls or anything like that.
The difference with the Super Skrull
is that he has the ability to mimic
the powers of other superheroes,
and that's not what these girls are doing.
They're just turning their bodies
into different types of weapons.
The way they explain
the villains in the movie
is that within TALOS, this larger
group of Skrulls
that he's been leading this whole time
since the events of the Captain
Marvel movie,
some of them have grown tired,
waiting for a new place to live, like
Nick Fury promised them in the nineties
that he would find them a new planet,
a new place to live,
and he hasn't done that so far.
So a group of them
just get pissed off at waiting
and they just decide to take the earth
like, well, the earth is here.
Why don't we just make this our home?
And that's where you get to the whole plot
of them taking over the planet.
So this isn't meant to be like
a completely separate
group of skrulls from a different planet.
It's meant to be from within their own
group.
The reason Samuel L Jackson said that
Nick Fury hasn't been back to Planet Earth
since Avengers Endgame
is because the events of Endgame,
the Blip, Avengers, Infinity War,
the Snap, Thanos, everything,
the deaths of the Avengers or some of
the Avengers just completely broke him.
That's why during the trailer
they reference where The Avengers
because Nick Fury hasn't
put together a new team of Avengers yet,
and he's basically telling TALOS
and the others in the trailer, Well,
this is the reason I showed up
because things got so bad.
We'll see him actually
come back to planet Earth on a spaceship.
Samuel L Jackson also said the reason
why he's not wearing his eyepatch during
most of the series, or at least see him
during most of the trailer.
Not wearing the eyepatch
is that he seems like
a much more vulnerable character
than he did in the previous Marvel movies,
like Phase one, Phase two, Phase three.
He was meant to be the person
who had all the answers and knew
where everything was headed.
But now, after all that, he has no idea
what's going on.
So he's
scrambling on the backs of his heels,
trying to catch up
with all this evil group of skrulls
and what they've been doing
this whole time.
There was the at least part of the series
takes place
in Russia around the Kremlin here
where there's a large explosion.
The evil group of Skrulls
start to make it seem like
a couple of wars are breaking out.
People wondering who are responsible,
like you see Maria Hill here monitoring
them while the explosion goes off.
Later in the trailer,
Rhodey says that he is like the most
wanted person in the world right now.
Damage control is after him.
Pretty much all the other world
governments around him.
It sounds like the evil skrulls
impersonate him
to make people think that he's behind
all these attacks in the way.
Cobie Smulders explain.
Maria Hill
is that she's been trying to contact
Nick Fury about all this trouble
with this bad group of Skrulls for years,
and he hasn't been answering her calls.
But this whole time
since Avengers Endgame,
Maria Hill
has been running around the planet
trying to put out these smaller fires
as this group of skrulls starts
to do crazier and crazier things.
You notice they get a brand new custom
version of the Marvel logo.
Like most of the Disney Plus series,
the colors a little bit different.
It's a little bit greener like the green
of the logo, the secret invasion.
You also see a little bit
of blood splatters on the logo itself.
Then we go to Great Britain
and we find out what's going on
with Sonia Falls, where she's meant to be
the daughter of the original union Jack,
who was a member of the Howling
Commandos back
during the first Captain America movie.
But the way Olivia Colman talks about her
character, she is Stone cold, kind of
like a British version of Val doing really
tough things to protect Great Britain.
So even though it seems like she's
working with Nick Fury,
she's meant to be kind of in antagonist
on the side next to the other real
antagonists, this evil group of Skrulls.
When she says old friend,
it sounds like they've
been working together for a long time.
When you see TALOS confront the Evil
Skrull graphic here,
you notice that the room
when all the other skrulls behind him
change into him
just to show him how they're everywhere.
The actual room that they're in
has all these banners of different
important world leaders just highlighting
what their grand plan is like.
We're going to slowly
replace all the world leaders.
The big rumors
that's going to include the U.S.
president and Rhodey right now
as the events of this series
has become the right hand
man, advisor to the U.S.
president.
It's not Thunderbolt Ross yet
he will become the U.S.
president.
But it sounds like they'll either find out
that the current U.S.
president is a skrull himself
or gets assassinated in that paves
the way for Thunderbolt
Ross to take the presidency
by the events of Captain America four.
But that's what you see.
Nick Fury
meeting with Rhodey of all people.
He's trying to inform him
about all the Skrulls
infiltrating world governments,
and he's close to the president.
So that's why he wants Rhodey to know
he has.
How much do you know
about your security detail?
And Rhodey is like, What?
What are you talking about?
We find out
that he's been using his gravesite
or the fake gravesite
to just hide some extra weapons,
which is a very Nick Fury
kind of thing to do.
Speaking of untold Nick Fury story,
there's a rumor that his wife is in this,
played by this character here, like
Nick Fury has had a fight this whole time.
There's references to his home life
during the events of Captain America
Winter Soldier as well.
It sounds like they'll explain
a little bit of that during this.
Maybe not his entire backstory,
but a little bit of his untold story
that you didn't get in the other Avengers
or the other Marvel movies.
You also notice in the mausoleum here,
zoom in and hands on these plaques here
representing the different people
that are buried here.
Some of these look like star charts.
When Sonia Foxworth Union
Jack is talking about the war
fight in the Shadows,
it sounds like they've
either been using some of the skrulls
for cloak and dagger stuff like the U.S.
government, the British government
have been using these skrulls
for special missions,
and then some of the skrulls
just turn against them,
like you see them looking at this group
of a bunch of skrull bodies
in stasis here are either dead
bodies or bodies that they've captured.
These might have been skrulls
that they had working for them.
Like it sounds like
a very valid type of twist where the U.S.
government, the British government,
wind up being responsible
for a lot of the problems
that happened during the series,
like the governments
have been taking advantage of the skrulls
this whole time,
using their abilities to their own ends.
We see Emilia Clarke for the first time
in this new trailer
with a bunch of new footage
she's supposed to be playing
Gia, who's Taylor's daughter?
There's a rumor
that by the end of the series,
she might wind up taking the Abigail
brand name as her alias
and being a version of that character
from the comics.
Not like the actual Abigail brand,
but she'll be a lot like Abigail Brand,
and they'll just use that name
for her character.
This is what she looks like
in her skrull form, though.
She's meant to be the little girl
from the Captain Marvel movie that you saw
Talus reunite with when he reunited
with his wife on Marvel's spaceship.
It's just that she's grown up since then.
The way that Emilia Clarke explains her
character is that she does
want to be a good person, but
she gets tied up with these evil skrulls
and she's kind of resentful of Nick Fury
because he hasn't delivered on his promise
of finding the skrulls a true home.
She's also a little estranged
from her father, Talos.
So ultimately,
she is going to help Nick Fury in Talos
But it's not like she's playing
the skrull empress or anything like that.
So when Sonya falls, Failsworth is telling
Nick Fury, Do you feel responsible
for everything that's happening
now with this evil group of Skrulls
that's just paying off the idea
that Nick Fury hasn't
delivered on his promise
and that's why they grown so distant?
Like,
we're tired of waiting for a new home.
We're going to take this earth
for ourselves.
He got a little sidetracked with Thanos
the infinity gantlet, the snap, the blip.
Otherwise he might have been able
to find them a home.
We see Everett Ross come back.
There was a little bit of new footage
of him.
Remember, he's a fugitive from justice
because Val ordered his arrest
after finding out what he was doing
in Black Panther.
Well, Connor forever
helping the Wakandans.
There's a French newspaper that references
The Avengers in the Battle of New York.
I can't see the data on this,
so we don't know
which Battle of New York it's referencing.
It could be the one in Avengers Endgame.
It could be the one
from the first Avengers movie.
I think most of the references in
this are to Avengers Endgame, though.
Just because we're moving the timeline
forward,
we see more of the skrulls secret base
in this Russian abandoned power plant.
It seems that they're trying
to create this weird device.
Lot of rumors
that this could have something
to do with them trying to create
super skrulls like extra powerful skrulls.
The actual super skrull in the Marvel
Comics
is tied heavily to the Fantastic Four,
so don't know how many Easter eggs.
We'll see for that during this series.
Okay, we'll see an actual Super Skrull
by the end of the series, but
that might be what they're trying
to create with all this extra power.
Like why would they need
all this extra juice?
This should seem like a group of skrulls
trying to attack either
the presidential convoy
or some other world
government leaders convoy.
When Emilia Clarke's
character tells Nick Fury
You don't know what
they have planned for you,
I think the idea is that
skrulls are trying to replace Nick Fury
because he's so connected to everything.
They be able to gain access to all kinds
of technology, all kinds of connections
and take over the planet
much, much quicker.
You can let me know what you think
is inside the secret case.
They're like, very Quentin Tarantino.
Show me what's inside the case.
Everybody thinking about Samuel L Jackson
with the case in Pulp Fiction,
it just says it's a specimen container
and it's from damage control.
We see Nick Fury confront
grabbing the main villain
at this Russian power plant
at the secret base, their special device.
So it seems like this will be towards
the conclusion of the series,
this scene of gravity using his powers.
All Groot like to grow his hand out
and snatch somebody.
Seems like it's
connected to that clip of the helicopters
with the skrulls taking out that convoy.
The big thing, though,
the end of the trailer,
he ends the trailer saying one last fight,
making it sound like Nick Fury
plans on dying during the series.
But the whole joke here is that
he's at his own gravesite.
He's already been pretending to be dead
this whole time.
So even if they do pretend like he's dead
at the end of the series,
I think that'll be a faint.
And he'll be back during Avengers five.
Qing Dynasty.
Avengers six Secret wars like Samuel L
Jackson will continue to come back as Nick
Fury as long as Marvel.
Kevin Feige, you will have him back.
Generally, the whole vibe of the series
is meant to feel a lot more like
Captain America Winter Soldier just doing
the Secret Invasion comic book storyline.
With a few exceptions,
like every single Avengers
character isn't going to be in this.
Like a squirrel isn't going to run around
pretending to be Spider-Man.
But the whole idea is that Marvel
is using Secret Invasion to set off this
whole Dark Reign era in Marvel Phase five,
where the villains start to take over
because it's characters like Val
and Thunderbolt Ross trying to seize
control,
using fear coming out of secret invasion
like the world finds out what the Skrulls
are trying to do.
Oh, my God.
They're trying to take us over.
We need to protect ourselves
in Thunderbolt Ross Valve,
those kinds of people take credit
for getting rid of the skrulls
and ride that wave of popularity
to even greater power.
Thunderbolt Ross becoming the new U.S.
president and paying off that line
from Avengers Age of Ultron,
where Iron Man wanted to protect the world
by wrapping it in a suit of armor.
And the Hulk was like,
That doesn't sound like a great thing.
Like, what about our personal freedoms?
Basically implying that a world like that
would be more akin to a police state.
But that's what Thunderbolt Ross and Val's
grand plan is during Marvel Phase five.
But because the series is coming out
in June,
we'll start getting more footage
really soon.
So of course I'll do more videos.
If you have any questions
about the characters
or the plot that's going on during this,
just write up below in the comments.
They'll be a brand new Blue Beetle trailer
from DC tomorrow and then the day after
that will be a brand new Spider-Man.
Across the Spider-Verse trailer.
There's supposed to be a billion Easter
eggs in that.
Of course I'll do videos for everything.
Everyone click here for that
brand new Guardians of the Galaxy
3 trailer video and Easter Eggs
and click here for that other new secret
invasion trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.